[Music]
ever since we announced diablo
4 at last blizzcon 2019 we've been
sharing updates with you guys
through our blog whether it's items
skills zones even user interface updates
and
you guys seem to have really enjoyed
that today to mark the the special
location
of blizzcon line on blizzard's 30th
anniversary
rather than doing a blog where we're
actually going to share lots of video
introduce a new class like we saw in
opening ceremonies
and also cover some open world topics
including
mounds camps and pvp yeah this is like
the ultimate blog post right
we get to actually hand deliver it this
is the dream
it's all come it's all finally out there
and we can talk about all of it
just in case some of you guys missed it
your opening ceremony let's take another
look at the rogue announce video
[Music]
there is justice within the light
but you have to be patient
now pray with me
may he shepherd my soul may he
shepherd my and granted
mercy and granted
mercy what are you doing here
this is not the time but this
is confession
and i have sinned
i was a thief who stole
from those more fortunate
i strayed from your light
and found my trade in the shadows
they call it murder
i say job well
done
i am a thief a heretic
a murderer father
will akara save me
hmm you mark our light
but those monsters with a scourge upon
my frog
and you
oh you were the answer to their prayers
then we are settled and you owe me
the name you seek is
thank the heavens for you
heavens i assure you father
the heavens didn't send me
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow i i love that ending
there's two things there's the there's
the rain of arrows off the mount for the
win
and then when that guy takes the air and
he stretches it on to that that that
that hook right at the end it's like oh
that ear box never gets old you know you
i always wonder where all those ears
from diablo 2 when you uh kill other
players went
now you know there's some creepy guy in
a church collecting ears and putting him
in a box
just what we always thought no spoilers
but uh we're gonna be hearing a little
bit more about uh world pvp
a little bit later in the segment but
ears are definitely making a comeback
but let's go back to the class because
there's just nothing more exciting to be
able to
introduce to diablo game than another
class for players to check out
yeah this is uh this is a pretty cool
thing we don't get to do this very often
right
i think it was uh you that said that
john there's always room around the
campfire
we had uh kind of like a very core
archetypes to begin with
the brute strength of the barbarian the
arcane knowledge of the sorceress
kind of a return of a shape-shifting
classic with the druid
no rpg lineup is complete without that
dexterity class that's
kind of like defeating enemies with
finesse with speed
and we kept coming back to just the idea
of bringing it to the
kind of the godfather of all dexterity
based archetypes
the the rogue that we saw in diablo one
i mean you got to be excited to have the
rogue back i mean i know that like when
we were exploring different classes
like you had talked about some of your
experience with with diablo one right
oh for sure so one of one of the things
that's super cool is like
the the the road was always able to uh
adapt their play styles the fans of
diablo 1 diablo 2 rogues will be able to
create very archetypical rogues
starting with the weapon selection on
the melee weapon side rogues can use
swords and daggers
as well as bows and crossbows on the
ranged side
you know just the those sort of dagger
attacks mixed with bow attacks it's like
it just looks great on screen with all
the classes having this real
strong identity as far as the animations
and what they do you think about the
the druid and shape-shifting or the
barbarian with sort of you know his leap
attacks
um there's just all these great things
that you discover with the rogue that
you can't really do with other classes i
love that you can start
cosmetically from such a iconic place
where you're wearing the red armor you
kind of look like part of the
sisterhood of the the sightless eye from
the original games
you know you can maybe even uh add some
tattoos into the mix some scars
make that rogue your own or if your
fantasy of the rogue is
a more uh traditional rpg outlaw you're
definitely able to
create that and put on your kind of hood
and half mask and
be more of a shadowy character yeah and
the character customization
you kind of mentioned it being able to
craft that you know that the the class
of your your dreams or your nightmares
it was a feature that i was honestly
super nervous about when we started
because
we never had this in a diablo game but
seeing where it is now is one of those
things that like i'm super excited about
with where we're at there's just a lot
of creativity and fun looks and you can
be that
that you know tattooed criminal outlaw
or you can be a more noble looking kind
of
you know sort of like thief with uh with
good morals
well one of the things that that we kind
of kept running with beyond just the
cosmetics what was customization
we had this uh this niche to fill in the
class lineup that that spoke to the the
finesse player to the dexterity player
and just that everyone's idea of what
that could be was a little bit different
whether
um it leaned more on range or melee but
uh
we we took that a little bit of a step
further we really wanted to have
each class in our game have just have
that one thing that makes you go like
that's [ __ ] when you see
a player use it and that makes you want
to re-roll that class because no other
class gets it
for the rogue is the class
specialization the three specializations
are combo points shadow realm
and exploit weakness i like shadow rom
because i can
i i take the problem and i make it
smaller i mean
it's just i just pull three guys into
the shadow realm and duke it out
and then i come back in i'm like all
right smaller problem
i i love the idea of exploit weakness
the way it works is uh
during some of the enemy attacks players
will see an icon flash over the enemy's
head during which time
they will get to retaliate with much
more damage than an ordinary attack
if you're quick on the draw this is the
specialization for you
i'm i'm just like a little bit skill cap
there and you know like
every time i try to make it work i'm
just just a little bit shy of the skill
level uh that's required for that
it's almost like you're a surgeon and it
requires a really
uh strong ability to assess what's
happening
all around you my my favorite my
personal favorite is the combopone
specialization
as you might expect this ability lets
you build multiple combo points
which enhance your spenders
effectiveness in combat
basically you just like get into this
rhythm of combat of like three builders
whose spender
lets you build up to these big big
moments it almost makes like a rhythm
game out of combat which i really enjoy
and the way the class specializations
work is uh you will work with one of the
world groups
of rogues uh around the world in
sanctuary that you will find
and do class-specific quests that no
other class can do
whether it's the sisterhood of the
sightless eye the remnants of that order
that you choose to work with
or the mercenaries of kaja stan or the
you know the outlaw smugglers of the
swamps of hawazar
depending maybe on what speaks to your
class fantasy or depending on which
specialization speaks to you or you
found more powerful
you'll be able to complete that
questline and then activate that that
specialization
which then you can mix and match with
any of the play styles
so you could be a combo points ranged or
melee player but you could also be an ex
exploit weakness range or melee or
hybrid player
it just gives the class such such huge
variety in builds and play styles
i love how that ties into the open world
aspect you know the ability to go
to kejustan or hauzar and get these
special quests that only the road can
get
that touches on one of the things that i
love that we've done which is like
connecting
the weapons and equipment to regions
when you're when you're exploring the
world
and you pick up a sword in kazakhstan
it's a it's a scimitar
right if you're up in scotland which is
up in the north it's more of like a
broadsword
um you know it's this sort of like this
it's a subtle thing but
i think it really you know different
armors that you get in different regions
look like they're from the place
um and so giving that sense of place in
the world is something that
i i just i every time i play the game i
feel it
i see it in just like subtle ways and
just really enhances the overall
sense of immersion and experience and i
just want to see what's around the
corner
the weapons uh are also like going back
all the way to diablo ii uh just such an
integral part of the class and the
ability to
augment your weapon through magic
through enhancements uh it is just
something that
really spoke to us when we try to tap
into the core of the class
um going back to the those mercenaries
that you could hire
it was always kind of cool to see what
kind of uh special uh
arrow shot they would they would come
with um and it's something we paid
homage to with
the imbue system um all the way from
directly elemental imbues like uh the
frost and view which
feels uh a lot like the the the ice
arrows that the d2 mercenaries used to
shoot
all the way to uh we expanded to feel a
little grittier a little darker into
things like poison and view and shadow
imbue
uh just the ability to take any any sort
of attack and kind of
mix and match with those imbues once
that kind of clicked for me that i could
take any ability and imbue it with
you know either of those elements uh
rain of arrows with frost and rain of
arrows with
acid is completely different right like
you're essentially freezing the
battlefield
um and then i just love poison view
because of the
the gruesome death that all the monsters
experience
uh and we've had a ton of fun making
that art so it's always fun to kind of
see the
you know just a field of goatman melt
into nothing you know you just kill
everything on the screen in a
in a in a gory mess uh which i i never
really gets old
it's a really flexible way to take a
build that you're already comfortable
with that you already like
say you you know you're really
comfortable with flurry and shadow stuff
as kind of your melee skills and you
find yourself needing more
uh crowd control without changing your
play style you can just add the frosting
view
to your bar and now you're able to use
those same ability to
slow down enemies or build up to a full
freeze yeah and frost and view plays
pretty well with uh group play as well
right
you know where i can freeze an enemy and
somebody else can blow it up or also
uh the way that like uh chills work in
the game uh
they build up to a full freeze so if you
you know your best buddy is a sorceress
player
uh your chill spells and your frost
abuse uh chills will actually build up
uh faster than if you were uh
using a single player so you know just
uh asked to open with blizzard before
you frost and view and
you'll you're basically freezing enemies
twice as fast which is super awesome
synergy so the last thing um
that's worth spending some time talking
about the rogue is like
how mobile the class is just how able
the class is to kind of close the gap
between themselves and the enemy
even while they're mounted you might
find yourself you know a full screen
away
and just dismounting into a rain of
arrows closing the rest of that gap with
uh maybe like a dash
and then getting back out of there
dropping some caltrops
they can basically control the the fluid
motion of combat in a way that no other
class can
uh that's something that beyond all of
the other
customization options that you have
whether it's the play style whether it's
the range at which you engage with
enemies
whether it's the cosmetics just the
sheer mobility of the class uh
lets you just adapt to the situations
even
even when you you would have totally
been toast as another class a room full
of elites
you're able to use offensive abilities
in creative ways
abilities like uh shadow stuff right
like abilities like shadow realm
abilities like dash
you're able to kind of like use them to
your advantage in a way that gets you
out of a very dangerous situation
by picking that one lone uh skeleton
archer
that maybe is not surrounded by
everything else you can shadow step
there get out of the way and you know
lift to fight another day which just
feels like such a rogue thing to do
when i play the rogue i really do feel
like like surgical precision you know i
really feel like i can
i can move through the whole screen uh
without it feels kind of effortless
um and almost sometimes a little unfair
it's like when i go into shadow realm
and i'm dashing
i'm like am i cheating did i just break
the game and we'll hear
more about pvp in a little bit but i i
just couldn't
go without mentioning that some of our
most feared pvp players on the team
play rogue and just the way they're able
to like surprise you you might be with a
group of friends and
just that mobility lets them go to the
middle of the group unleash a reign of
arrows that's frost imbued and before
you know it you're all frozen
and looking at a rogue while you're
frozen let me tell you
there are fewer scarier things in our
game right now than that
so louise this was uh i mean this is
like the ultimate blog post this has
been a lot of fun getting to share
a new addition to the campfire um and of
course there's probably gonna be more in
the future right we always say there's a
little bit more room around that
campfire that's right and that pretty
much
wraps it up for the road so why don't we
go to joe and karina and learn a little
bit more about those open world features
that we promised
well thank you to luis and john for
introducing the rogue
which i'm i'm really excited that we
finally got a chance to talk about and
announce to the community and we're here
today to talk to you about
diablo 4 and the open world now i think
maybe the
the best way to start this conversation
uh karina would be just to for me to ask
you like what are you
what are you most excited about what
we're adding in diablo 4 for the open
world
what feature what what mechanic what
what are you most excited to talk about
first
i am really excited about uh
just exploring the world i am a huge
completist
naturally that's the way i play and i
love exploring and looking after every
single nook and cranny the more
this game has been growing particularly
since last blizzcon
um the more fun i am having just riding
around the open world on my mount and
exploring everything i possibly can
yeah it's it's really fun i think uh now
that we've kind of taken sanctuary and
just made it so much
larger when you're playing through the
game you know when you compare it to
like diablo 3 or diablo 2
there's tons of like exploration and and
and um
and movement throughout the world in
those games obviously but
now that we've really been able to
embrace the open world concept
we can really dive much deeper into like
what
how does sanctuary actually all fit
together like be able to ride from
uh ska's glen to the fractured peaks
like like it's very very interesting
that way one of the things about that
that i think is really neat is
uh the collection aspect of mounts
so i mean there's all these horses horse
breeds and other
other mounts you can find throughout the
world from completing puzzles
or just finding hidden locations or
slaying certain particular kinds of
monsters
find various horses or things to
customize your horse with like
like a horse armor there are hoof plates
you can get
and trophies to show off your
accomplishments there's lots of
different ways to make sure that you can
personalize your mount make it really
feel like it's your companion yeah it's
really cool that like like you mentioned
the whole shoes you get to actually
change the speed at which your holes can
run and it's something i like
to be able to customize the horse to the
type of gameplay that i like to enjoy as
a player
that's that's really really fun i like
the amount of variety that you give us
and i mean there's there's more to
mounts than just that as well it's like
one thing we know we didn't want to do
with mounts in diablo 4 is we didn't
want to have like jousting
this idea of like fighting from
horseback it's not really the diablo
experience
right yeah that's something i'm super
excited for um
like we showed at last blizzcon we had
the sorceress we showed her
dismount skill eye stash where she
shoots forwards off her amount and
destroys everything in her
path but with the rogue we got to have a
little bit more fun with it and the
animation department has done a
fantastic job of
having her leap up into the air and fire
down
like the reign of arrows that destroys
everything it's
really really cool it feels really good
yeah like leaping from your saddle and
just
raining arrows down on your enemies as
you pass by
getting down the frame and then starting
to front like stab people and poison
people like
that that is that is spot on what we're
looking for being able to jump in
engage with enemies from your horse and
then just
fight it out duke it out using your
skills and everything else like we want
it's interesting that
your mount can't get damaged but if a
monster actually attacks you while
you're mounted you will actually be
forced to dismount so there is a
flip side of actually judging for
yourself when you do want to use that
skill in order to prevent you from being
forced off unintentionally
yeah there's definitely a little bit of
gameplay there to make sure that you're
using it in a way that is most
appropriate to help you get where you're
trying to go
and also fight the monsters you want to
fight one of the things i'm most excited
about for the uh for the open world
right now is this feature we have called
camps so camps are basically these uh
strongholds of evil out in the overworld
now you gotta remember that you know
decades ago uh during the events of
reaper of souls
you know when malthiol rose to power the
reapers killed like nine out of ten
people
uh throughout sanctuary like a
tremendous number of people passed away
uh now there's a big power vacuum out
here you know you know decades later and
these these monsters have started to
move into these places
bandits monsters goat men all kinds of
different creatures
skeletons the undead have started to
like resurface and come back into these
areas and start to take them for
themselves
you as the hero of sanctuary gets to
kind of wander through these spaces
and begin to reclaim them for the people
of sanctuary
that's part of what makes them really
really neat each of them have their own
story they're their own unique fixed
place in the world unlike quests quest
is something that happens randomly in
the world and
you can come across them anyway camps
are a permanent fixture that
you as the player when you come across
that evil you can actually have a real
impact on the open world that everyone
else can see because
once you have defeated that evil um one
of the really fun things is that
you you basically unlock that camp and
you you make a new waypoint that
previously didn't exist for yourself but
like
suddenly all the marketplaces open up
and now you have a blacksmith vendor and
a location that previously didn't exist
which i think is really really cool
now what we're looking at here uh this
was a village
at the village of cara yosu which now
has fallen to ruins
you know the people here in the dry
steps had a problem the problem was
their were bloodthirsty cannibals that
dwelled nearby and would regularly raid
their community
and the people had come up with a
solution they weren't strong enough to
defend themselves from these cannibals
so they made a dark bargain with a demon
and they were able to
gather enough power to push these
cannibals out and protect their
community
but not without great cost as we can see
here you're kind of helping resettle
parts of sanctuary in many ways when you
take these camps back from the enemy
vendors will come back and now suddenly
there might be like new quest givers new
stories need to be told
dungeon entrances can appear in some of
these places afterwards like there's all
kinds of things that occur
after you take over the camp and
liberate it from these forces of
darkness
and again it's just so so cool to see
you permanently change the world
as you find these places and kind of
want you and solve these problems
one of the other neat things about camps
and in general like the overworld just
broadly speaking
is we have so many more opportunities
now uh to kind of play with movement
it pushes the the bar vertically as well
as horizontally
and we now have been playing around with
the idea of jumping across chasms
to allow the player to get access to a
location that they previously didn't
have
there's uh there's all kinds of areas
players like find their own path
allowing them extra movement options
they haven't had in previous diablo
games we are also in a vertical
top-down camera for the environment and
so it really breaks
up the plane that you typically see as
like not only as a developer as an
animator but also as a player there's
such a huge variety of
things that you can possibly do to mix
it up and make things a little bit
different
there's like certain puzzle elements to
it that it's not so straightforward and
not always obvious so
it's not just a matter of running
through the world and getting
you know to your goal is you have to
think about it yeah definitely
now karina i know that you're very
excited about pvp
i'm a huge fan of pvp i love the first
time that we all actually had a chance
to as a whole team play pvp because the
amount of feedback that that generated i
think it took design like three days to
go through it all
and what that showed me is that i find
everyone either they either love it or
they hate it
and i personally love it i really enjoy
it so the way that pvp works is that
the uh hatred of mephisto has been
bubbling up from hell
and has created these areas in the open
world that you can freely walk into
that kind of consumes you and makes you
turn against your fellow
players pvp even in these areas these um
these fields of hatred right uh even in
these spaces it's not like mandatory so
these are optional places players can
choose to go
uh to kind of collect shards of hatred
that they can they can collect from like
killing monsters
from completing events opening chests
all kinds of ways to earn these things
not necessarily just killing players
and as you earn these shards of hatred
they're kind of in an unpurified state
they're in a basic state
you need to bring them to a purification
event
in order to turn them into a currency
that you can then use
in the nearby like small encampments
around the fields of hatred what's
really neat about that
is that when you're trying to purify
these things that's when everybody
nearby
finds out and here's like okay well
someone's actually trying to complete a
publication which will mean to go
and kill those players and take all of
their shards before they finish
but once you purify them they're yours
you can't lose them but uh
but before they're purified their free
game yeah i think it's really important
to note that like
even if you don't want to engage with
other pvp players you can actually
explore those areas and collect the
shadows of hatreds from specifically
monsters
but the second you need to then turn
them in and purify them into a currency
where you can spend them on gear
trophies and other content you actually
are hostile yourself and actually can be
attacked during that single moment but i
think that really
creates a lot of opportunity for you to
team up with friends for just that one
little moment in order to gain the
reward that you spent so much time
collecting
so you call out earlier that uh the
shards of hatred are used for like some
of the vendors you could find in the
fields of hatred
uh there are some special vendors that
only kind of arrive in these areas
we'll have special costumes or new
mounts
and weapons and things along those lines
nothing that's like strictly more
powerful than stuff you can get other
parts of the game
but stuff that really like speaks to
your desire as a pvp player
and i think one of the things that's
really kind of neat about the system in
general is that
as a player if you choose to go hostile
betray your other up betray the players
that are near you
try to get as many shards of hatred as
you can you're going to slowly begin to
kind of like
infuse yourself with that same curse of
mephisto
you're going to become a vessel of
hatred now once you do that
everyone within a very large radius of
you is able to see you
as a threat on the map and they're going
to get a bonus for killing you
so if when that occurs you have a set
amount of time you need to survive
and if you're able to do that without
running away or jumping a town portal
and trying to escape
if you're able to do that and finish
that period and manage to escape or
or defeat your you know people who are
coming to try to destroy you
you're going to get a really big bonus
at the end and that's been really really
exciting to watch in our play tests
already is people like kind of wrestling
for the status and then trying to defend
it once they actually achieve it yeah
and
there's also the ears that you get to
collect as a trophy um it harkens back
to d2 where i think you could
sell the ears for one gold i don't know
if we're going to be doing that i know
we were playing around with them
as a currency at one point but i think
right now it's just a cool trophy that
you get to collect and show off
yeah right now very very cool trophy the
thing was really neat about the diablo 2
ears like you could fill up your whole
inventory with them obviously but
being able to see like the uh the people
that you took the ears from like seeing
their their character names on there
was always like the really the
interesting fun part kind of proof like
yeah i got
i got that person that time right so we
want to make sure that we embrace that
aspect of it that's the important part
for
us i think that's going to be a really
really great call back to diablo 2 pvp
right yeah so i'm i'm i love where pvp
is going and i love that it is such a
it's only one part of how large and open
the world
is and really harkens back to the
adventure in me when i play the game how
do you feel
i'm super excited as well i mean there's
so much to look forward to in diablo 4
right now like what we talked about
today just scratches the surface
in general as a diablo fan there's a lot
to be looking forward to in the free on
the franchise in the future
thank you so much for watching today we
look forward to speaking to you more
about this game and others in the future
you